LAK LAKSHMANAN: How many
of the tables in your data
warehouse have location
information in them?
Perhaps you record the latitude
and longitude of your vehicles
or packages over time.
Or maybe you have the
addresses of your customers
and suppliers.
Maybe you recorded
customer transactions
and you could join it
against another table that
has store locations.
Not only is location
information very common,
many business decisions
revolve around location--
who to send out coupons
to, whether the package
will reach on time.
Therefore, geospatial
analysis is
quite common in data analytics.
9% of .sql files in GitHub
carry out spatial queries.
That's why I'm happy to
show you a new feature that
makes analyzing and visualizing
geospatial data in BigQuery
very easy and highly performant.
GHCN Daily is a public
data set of weather data,
and the stations table contains
latitude and longitude columns.
In another table,
I have information
about postal codes used by the
United States Postal Service.
There are two
columns in this table
that are of interest here.
The WKT, or Well-Known
Text, is a format
for representing geographies.
In this case, it is a polygon.
The postal code,
called the ZIP code,
is the second column
that we're interested in.
So let's run a query that
finds all the weather
stations within 10
kilometers of a ZIP code.
I'm pulling the ZIP code
polygon and the weather station
location.
And then in my WHERE clause, I
am filtering using ST_DWithin--
distance within.
I'm checking whether
the station's
latitude and longitude, which
form a geographic point--
whether that point is within
10 kilometers of the ZIP code
polygon.
And if you look at
the results, there
are two stations that
are inside the polygon
itself, so their distance is 0.
And there are 28 total stations
within 10 kilometers of the ZIP
code.
This is great but if
you have spatial data,
you want to visualize it.
You want to visualize
it on a map.
The BigQuery Geo Viz is a
convenient way to do this.
So here I have the same
query in the Geo Viz.
I can select the
geometry column and then
click Run to get a map
of the weather stations.
I can also style the points
based on some other column
in the data.
Here's another query that
shows off the ability
to style things in the map.
This time, I'm joining the
census data set of population
with ZIP code boundaries.
Let's make the polygon
column-- the WKT column--
the geography and
change the colors
and opacity of the polygons
based on population.
As you can see, BigQuery GIS
provides a convenient, powerful
way to incorporate
spatial information
into your decision-making,
even as your data sets
growing into the petabytes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]